you
all right what's up everybody
this is a kind of last second stream I
put together really the whole point is
we want to test streaming at the same
time to both twitch and YouTube just to
see how the whole thing works and it is
it is working we are live on both twitch
and YouTube right now although something
weird happened with YouTube where we had
we had an event scheduled and then when
we started the stream it like bypassed
the event and started a whole separate
thing it's really weird I don't know
what's up with that but that seems like
a detail generally speaking it seems to
be it seems to be working super chats
are working and twitch prime
subscriptions are working simultaneously
so this is the first time we've done it
actually we thought last week we were
thinking let's get the biggest possible
audiences for the impeachment hearing
streams and to do that we should really
do twitch and YouTube but we didn't
because it was too it was too risky to
do it for the first time when we knew
there would be six seven eight thousand
live viewers so I'm trying it now and
maybe this is something that we'll be
able to do in the future which is
exciting and great and I have a whole
bunch of stuff to talk about stories
that we're going to be doing on
tomorrow's show there's this huge Devin
Nunez story which is actually now
becoming a two-part story part one is
that one of the guys that works with
Rudy Guiliani who was arrested now says
actually he can implicate Devan newness
in the Biden Fiasco and if that's the
case then why is Devin Nunez asking
questions in the impeachment inquiry
hearings he should be a witness if
that's the case and we found out that
not only does he seem to be involved it
seems that you through taxpayer money
actually paid for Devin Nunez to fly
around and try to get dirt on Joe Biden
number two I have very interesting data
that one of our viewers put together
which looked at how does polling
compared to speaking time in the last
democratic debate which is very
interesting and there's actually like a
two layer analysis that we should do
you'll be doing and looking at and we're
gonna do that in a second and then
number three I do want to talk about
this Trump interview on Fox & Friends
which was just absolutely and totally
nuts and Trump promoted it and we're
going to look at it a little bit
momentarily so yeah so people are asking
now that we are live on both YouTube and
twitch what counts towards the the
website members it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you're watching on
YouTube and twitch everything counts and
if you're on twitch you've got the
Amazon Prime twitch subs if you're over
on YouTube we've got the super chats
which I will be looking at and one came
in already saying simply here's my super
chat so I predict we may have a lot of
audience participation here which would
be great so we're going to start with
the dev and newness thing and then then
go on from there
let's make sure all other settings are
sort of looking correct here yeah I
think they basically it seems like we're
working everything everything seems to
be working Breck Lee okay so let's let's
get right into it so if you watch the
impeachment hearings with me the other
day you like me probably noticed that
Devon Nunez as the ranking member got a
lot of speaking time Adam Schiff would
make an opening statement and then Devon
Nunez would get to speak and at the end
before the closing statement that Adam
Schiff made Devon Nunez would get a
chance to make a statement this is
because Devin Nunez is the ranking
member
basically the sort of like
second-in-command I guess you would say
on the House Intelligence panel so you
heard him say a lot of really dumb
things like apologizing up quote
apologizing to the witnesses about
ratings are done ratings are down for
this stream the impeachment hearing
stream or whatever and of course that
was a weird thing to tell the witnesses
because they're just there to answer
questions and tell the truth and not
perjure themselves he made the case that
this is all bogus that the real thing we
need to be looking at is Joe Biden and
hunter Biden and whatever else turns out
that Devin Nunez was meeting
with Ukrainians looking for Biden dirt
this is what we have now learned the
lawyer for an indicted associate of Rudy
Giuliani said his client is willing to
tell Congress that congressman Devin
Nunez of California met with a former
Ukrainian prosecutor and not just any
we'll get to that last year to discuss
investigating former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son hunter Biden Joseph
Bondi represents left Parnas who was
indicted last month on campaign finance
charges and claims his client heard
directly from the former Ukrainian
official about his meeting in Vienna
with Nunez who has become a key trump
defender in the impeachment inquiry mr.
Parnas learned from former Ukrainian
prosecutor general Viktor Shokan that
Nunez met with Shokan in Vienna last
December this guy Shokan is at the
center of a lot of this Shokan was fired
from his post as prosecutor in 2016
after a bunch of Western leaders
including Biden expressed concern that
he was in pursuing corruption cases now
the the theory which I've widely
debunked is that the rightists are the
trumpets are putting together Trump and
Nunez say Biden wanted Shokan to be
removed to protect his son Hunter Biden
there is no evidence of that at this
point in time so this is bad enough okay
if this is true you have a guy in Devin
Nunez who is participating significantly
in the impeachment inquiry hearings when
actually he is someone who should
arguably be a witness because he is part
of the attempted smear campaign on Joe
Biden and he gets to sit up there and
run interference for Trump he is
arguably a co-conspirator and he's
involved as a high-ranking a person on
the hearings which is absolutely and
totally stunning but it gets worse and
I'm going to I see that we've got super
chats on YouTube and we also have twitch
prime subscriptions to thank over on
over on twitch prime and I will I will
get on twitch I'll get to that it's not
just that Devin Nunez was doing this and
has no serious credible reason to stay
on the impeachment inquiry hearings if
they continue which Adam Schiff says
they will it appears
Devon Nunez was doing this on taxpayer
money which makes this closer to he
should simply resign rather than he just
shouldn't be on these panels congressman
Devon Nunez the ranking Republican
member on the House Intelligence
Committee spent nearly fifty seven
thousand dollars on a trip to Europe for
him and his staff to allegedly
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden the figures seemed to confirm
allegations made by Lev Parnas a
Ukrainian born American who worked as a
fixer for Rudy before being indicted
Parnas said he met Nunez in a secretive
trip to Vienna Austria my guess is if he
is making this allegation this assertion
my guess is partners can probably prove
it between November and December 2018
and put him in touch with former
Ukrainian prosecutor general Viktor
Shokan the lawyer who was ousted from
his position in 2016 after I as I
already told you
Western leaders including Biden and said
he was not doing enough to combat
corruption reports filed with the office
for the clerk show that Newman has
claimed expenses for a four-day trip to
Europe at the time in question between
November 30 and December 3 so as usual
consider how this is all gone you have
the William Taylor testimony and in that
testimony he says one of my staffers
overheard a phone call between Trump and
song hland and of course immediately the
trumpets say there's no evidence of that
that's not true that's just hearsay and
then of course we hear from David Hale
who was the witness to that phone call
and that is confirmed yesterday the day
before yesterday we hear allegations
that Devon Nunez is up to his neck in
the Joe Biden smearing while
simultaneously participating in the
hearings and they say oh it's just an
allegation we don't know if that's true
and then it just so happens that
financial records are found that match
up with this exactly and then you see
this is not super visible I apologize in
any case the records are there and it
all seems to match up perfectly every
single one of these stories that the
trumpets try to get a head out of and
say no no no there's nothing going on
then are confirmed that
corroborated how deep does it go
probably very very deep and we are going
to at some point I don't know when at
some point we were gonna find out a lot
about it okay
we are we are live on both twitch and
YouTube this is the first time we've
been trying this so first let me thank
some people over on Twitch for
subscribing with twitch prime which is
free if you have Amazon Prime thanks to
mr nano pod and arias Elyria for red fan
game path of Thera fiscal Diablo and de
hooker thank you so much let me also now
talk about some of the super chats that
have been coming in over on the YouTube
side this is we've never done this
before it is interesting and it seems to
be working at least for now babaganoosh
says you do more good than you know john
r says Republicans still on Russia
propaganda as Trump's defense yeah there
I mean listen it's you you've got to get
out of that paradigm because it'll rot
your brain Harvey willing says wrapping
up the inquiry pyramid prematurely would
be a historic mistake they're starting
to sweat turn up the heat I agree I
agree they are desperate now to say the
hearings were a dud and and get this
over with and I think it would be a
mistake to end it anytime soon there's
so many witnesses still that should be
called Mike Cooper says it's possible
the dam will break right listen Mike I
hope so but it there I took a call the
other day in fact I might play it for
you in a bit yeah let me let me actually
I'm just gonna take note of where that
let's see if I can find that call
let's see spectacularly there's a
there's a call that I think would be
interesting for us to listen to in a bit
yeah in fact we could maybe check it out
just momentarily that this this call was
a perfect example of why this may not go
anywhere no matter what happens because
they do not care about what the facts
are take a listen to this is from the
show last week take a listen
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 starting with Tim
Tim back in January I guess was the last
time we heard from you and
you were you were pretty angry from what
I have in my notes when we spoke back in
January is does that sound right I don't
know if I was angry I know we were
talking back and forth about health care
and how it would be what the hell was
gonna be paid for 50 cue trillion
dollars right and I I hate to interrupt
already but so that what's important
here is I start pointing out what he's
doing as he's doing it but I want you to
prepare you for it so that you watch for
it pay attention to how each topic that
he tries to go to fails and then he says
well that doesn't even really matter
what about this other thing even though
it's his topics that are being brought
up okay this is moving the goalposts
it's circular reasoning
it's fact-free reasoning it's everything
this is every third year I don't know
how you know with even the you know you
provided me I don't even know how it
would still be paid for but you know
regardless I was seeing that you were
doing a bunch of live streams on the
impeachment hearings and I wanted to see
you know what's your takeaway from
what's going on and what do you think
the outcome for Democrats would be
positive or negative well I've got a big
story coming out on this because on the
one hand you've had you know there have
been some people testifying who have not
really made a big impact but certainly
Gordon Sunland has made it clear that
everybody knew what was going on Rudy
Giuliani knew Mike Pompeo knew Mike
Pence knew Donald Trump knew everybody
knew about the extortion bribery quid
pro quo that should be extremely
damaging lieutenant colonel Alexander
VIN Minh had very devastating testimony
but I'll be honest with you Tim I said
if Democrats can't turn this into
something it will be very embarrassing
because they're monopolizing dozens of
hours of TV time across all networks it
is even in its most salacious moments
you still got to pay really close
attention for hours at a time to
understand what went on and I don't know
if Democrats are going to be able to
turn this into something and and on what
you just said I think it's also costing
the taxpayers tens of thousands of
dollars to hold these circus hearings to
begin with and when it comes to actually
breaking the law there
Ben you know substantial evidence of
anything that's why even you said they
don't have anything well no I do I never
I certainly never said they don't have
anything what I said is that so there's
a couple different things these are not
criminal it's tarts falling apart no
proceedings impeachment proceedings are
not criminal so we can talk about
criminal but that's actually that that's
a totally separate issue altogether it
relates to the Justice Department two
different things we don't want to mix
them up but I certainly severed never
say they don't have anything what I said
is as devastating as what they have is I
still am unsure I mean listen I just I
don't see impeachment happening
hopefully this will fire people up
enough that they vote Trump out in
November of 2020 that's that's for me
the most likely positive outcome that I
can imagine well isn't the impeachment
hearings in and of itself high crimes
and misdemeanors high crimes high crimes
means the person doing it not what the
crime is so there's a lot of
misunderstanding about what what that
even means but we're talking again you
can be impeached not because you
committed a felony for example but
because what you did abdicated the the
morality you abdicated the role of the
president you gave up sovereignty to a
foreign country there are things that
may or may not be crimes that are ever
prosecuted they can still be impeachable
so it's important not to confuse
criminal proceedings with impeachment
proceedings this also relates to due
process a lot of the conversation is
happening about you now he's going to
start going off and what kind of a
proceeding this is but it sounds like
you're watching the streams and and
that's good at least people are paying
attention yeah I mean I've been
following this pretty closely and you
know I followed this regularly and I see
that there doesn t there just seemed to
be hearsay from what I see on my end
from secondhand conversations no so this
is important he says the present buy
anything because it's all hearsay
now I explained to him it's not the case
and watch what he does patience Gordon
Sunland gave all firsthand testimony so
I don't know maybe you're defining here
here that's a Republican talking point
that there's one of that people say well
hold on that's a different question that
you first said that there's only hearsay
I pointed out that there isn't and now
you say
who cares no no no from the first two
proceedings that we had there was all
hearsay now we're having it from
directly from the horses now but that
still not giving Democrats anything to
work with
as you said previously I'm agreeing with
you in a sense but the reason that they
may not have anything to work with is
that you have 62% of Trumpets who said I
don't care what he ever does I will
never abandon him and when you're
dealing with people like that
he could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
and it wouldn't matter so I think it's
important to distinguish between there
is nothing versus Republicans won't care
and that's the situation that we have
Tim well the transcript is out okay so
now but he moved to a new thing which is
also untrue the entire transcript of the
call it out the American people have
read the transcript I haven't seen Don
granese released the full transcript
come per week the full transcript so we
a lot of the people and you will
continue this in a second I know that a
lot of the people that are watching me
right now you guys may not even pay that
close attention to politics you pay some
attention I'm guessing cuz you're here
most of you I get I would i would guess
know that the transcript was never
released what Donald Trump released was
it was a 30 minute phone call they took
what is about by my reading six or seven
minutes of the call it's it's a it's a
partial transcript it's a fraction of
the total call Trump keeps calling it a
transcript because he wants us to think
that what he released is everything but
it's not and I think most people in my
universe know that and if if you don't
then it's good for you know you to tell
me that because then I understand that
actor I shouldn't assume that you know
that this guy seems to have fallen for
it he seems to literally think that the
30 minute transcript is out when it when
it's not the 30 minute Trump released a
transcript that was about six or seven
minutes of a 30-minute phone call unless
it happened in the last five minutes
Trump has not released the full
transcript see this is the problem David
people's there is to be confused there
was an old transport was never
everything so so you first you now you
said the full transcript has been
it hasn't and now you're just saying
there is nothing you're doing circular
arguments
none of them based on fact every fact
you assert is wrong and then you move on
to something else too
the fact is there's no substantial
evidence for impeachment and you know
that and you know so now he's back to
something I so anyway I think the reason
we looked at that is that someone I
think via super chat said is the dam
going to break and it's like how could
the dam ever break with a guy like that
right I mean it's just not going to
happen and that that's why I think we
have to be careful but you know it's
like we have to just do the right thing
clearly we now have the impeachment
hearings were you you had Gordon Sunland
say there was a quid pro quo then Trump
comes out and says no I called them and
I literally said I don't want a quid pro
quo any normal person would say why are
you even talking about a quid pro quo
if the nope if there's no quid pro quo
we know why now and on and on and on so
it's you know I don't know that we will
ever convince them but if we can do
enough damage where Trump just loses in
November 2020 I think that's the
advantage I don't know if that's
happening and I'll have a story about
that tomorrow okay let me go through
super chats and then twitch messages we
are live on both twitch and YouTube
we've never done this before I know that
if I become a YouTube a twitch partner I
can't do this but I'm not a twitch
partner so that's okay we're doing it
we're live on both ms M dip sent a four
thousand columbium peso super chat I
think that's a dollar who says wait
there's a video someone catch me up
please yes there's video of Trump we
will get to that momentarily Kara Boras
and says sadly I doubt this will change
anything no matter what he does Trump
cultists will spin it into him being
some sort of mystical genius yeah I
basically agree with you and also Cal
eff says why do these people lie to
themselves I don't know that this guy
was lying to himself I I don't I don't
know that he was lying to himself I
think that he just believes a lot of the
stuff that has been floated around
thanks over on the twitch side to mowgli
for subscribing with twitch prime to
fusion nine sixteen to POTUS one bratty
while cord asparagus and king
- this is kind of a funny idea that that
some people had about what we should do
so you know how whenever we we do these
streams we sometimes have like a target
of website members like right now it's
15 and then we open up the phone lines
people both on Twitch and on YouTube are
suggesting that we do a contest between
twitch and YouTube everything counts to
the 15 but we see whether people are
using the YouTube or the twitch code and
I think we actually have the perfect
codes to do this if you're watching on
youtube and you want to grab a
membership and if we get to 15 up there
we'll open up the phone lines use the
code youtube' 50 okay that saves you 50%
the code is YouTube 50 it works on any
membership if you're watching on twitch
use the code half 19 both of them save
you 50% there's no difference we'll just
track whether we get more on twitch or
on YouTube and maybe the winner I will
do the next stream will be only on the
one that wins is that does that make
sense is that a good idea I don't know
yeah well we'll see we'll try it out
okay
let's continue am I missing anything
else I want to make sure Oh a Bridget
Lee Harding wants to know if the coupon
codes work at Olive Garden I wouldn't
know because I've never been I've never
been but that that that's um no I I did
go to I did actually go to Olive Garden
when was it I think it was about 15
years ago yeah some guy I know it was
his birthday
and he insisted on going to Olive Garden
and it was it was a difficult experience
for sure but I did it I survived and I
think that that's the most exciting
thing okay this is very very interesting
we have a variety of different people
who work in data science and all sorts
of different fields we have medical
professionals in the David Pakman show
audience we have you know people from
almost an airline pilots and all sorts
of stuff one of the things that I
received over the weekend is this chart
oh and actually we yang is not not
visible and yang is a key part of this
chart
this chart graphs screen time during the
recent CNN the order I'm sorry screen
time as measured by CNN from the recent
MSNBC debate and polling average for the
candidates okay this is like this is so
important and we're going to talk about
this on the broadcast show tomorrow so
if you watch the debate on MSNBC last
week you probably notice that not every
candidate got the same amount of
speaking time that that was that wasn't
difficult to tell and one of the things
that I've been saying is I think that
there are way too many people on the
stage there should be stricter
requirements and we should have way
fewer candidates and really at this
point
Booker Harris clos bit well Harris maybe
Booker Klobuchar Gabbard steyr and yang
probably shouldn't be participating in
the debate that the debates anymore just
based on the numbers okay and I know
people will argue if you like Tulsi
you'll say she should be there feel like
yang you'll say he should be there
forget it that's not the argument okay
I believe there should be fewer
candidates on stage but if you're gonna
have this number of candidates on stage
if they made it if the requirements may
allowed them to get in they should
probably get roughly the same amount of
time right because it's not if you make
the debate then you get to talk based on
your polling it should be if you made
the debate you're a participant full
fully right so that's been what what
I've been saying for a while however one
could make the argument that it makes
sense that the candidates get to speak
in proportion to how their polling what
would the argument I'm not making this
argument but somebody could make this
argument and say listen Biden Saran's
Sanders and Warren are the frontrunners
they should get the most time because
it's more likely that they'll win this
is not my argument okay I want to be
clear I think they should get equal time
but there should be fewer people on
stage so if you believe that they should
get equal to they should get time
proportionate to polling the next
question is did they did it simply
become an issue of if you're polling
better
you get more time and the answer is in a
sense yes but there were some people who
got way more screen time than their
polling would dictate and some people
who got way less screen time than their
polling would dictate and what this
graph is of is effectively to what
degree did screen time separate from the
expectation based on the polling and
what you saw is for example Bernie
Sanders basically got the screen time
that matches his polling okay Joe Biden
got relatively close to the screen time
that matches how well he's polling he
actually was below he if it went by
polling he should have had a little more
screen time or talk time but it honestly
it's probably better for Joe Biden to
talk less cuz when he talks it's a
disaster Elizabeth Warren maybe not
surprisingly the debate was on MSNBC
MSNBC has been relatively friendly to
Elizabeth Warren Warren got some more
time than polling would dictate but
here's where it gets really really
interesting
tulsi gabbard Tom Steyer and by the
biggest margin Andrew yang got way less
screen time or let's say Tulsi by about
the same amount as Biden but steyr and
yang got significantly less screen time
then their polling would suggest based
on Andrew Yang's polling which I guess
is right around 2.5 he should have had
more screen time than he got steyr is
polling less and he got more screen time
so he's closer to the line
so they got you could say got screwed if
you subscribe to this you get talk time
based on what you're polling but what's
very interesting is that Pete Buddha
judge by far if you look at the distance
from the line
Pete Buddha judge got the most screen
time relative to what he is polling and
that's not hugely surprising because he
has become a guy that the establishment
has sort of been getting behind and I
think that it's a problem not a Buddha
Judge guy and he got the biggest what I
would call an artificial boost beyond
what his polling suggests
then you have this cluster of three
establishment candidates who also got
more time than their polling would
dictate Cory Booker Kamala Harris and
Amy Klobuchar they are not polling well
and based on the amount of talk time
that they got they were given a bonus
talk time relative to what you would
expect based on how they are polling so
this is interesting in in a number of
different ways I reject that there
should even be you know if you make the
stage you're if you should just get
equal talk time but if you believe we
should hear more from candidates who are
polling better andrew yang by far got
screwed the most and Pete Buddha judge
got the sort of biggest gift as did
Elizabeth Warren and interestingly the
narrative has been and you know I don't
watch enough MSNBC to be able to say
this more than anecdotally but from what
I've read buddha jayan warren have been
sort of the recent favorites on MSNBC so
this is very very interesting and i so
appreciate that dave see one of our
viewers put this together and sent it to
me okay if there are questions on this i
will take questions on this in the
meantime let me say thanks to a few more
twitch prime subscribers i want to say
thanks to Fredi freeloader not a
freeloader anymore who is subscribed
with twitch prime auntie whipped to red
wolf 8 thanks for 2 months in a row
fiscal Diablo thanks for two months in a
row says my ten month old enjoys your
show very much that may be the youngest
david pakman show viewer and Gibby Gib
since 79 thank you for the twitch prime
subscriptions
let me also read a few of the super
chats that have come in on the YouTube
side Roxie Hart lines says Trump is
Skynet he has corrupted the whole system
all right and I guess that's it ok we
are also in meshed in a YouTube versus
twitch battle right now to see who uses
the YouTube code more or who uses the
twitch code more we have fil-a I'm gonna
have to keep like notes about this or
maybe someone else can track it okay
fil-a has signed up with the youtube
code youtube 50 thanks Phil I appreciate
that Skylar Grey has signed up with the
YouTube code that's to zero
YouTube winning right now John Harris
has signed up with the YouTube code
that's 3-0 YouTube muffins and Vidal has
signed up with the YouTube code that's
for zero oh twitch is getting crushed
and Josiah lusher has signed up with the
YouTube code so we have 5 of 15 website
members if we get to 15 I will open the
phone lines but we're also trying to
make this interesting YouTube vs twitch
and YouTube is winning 5 nothing right
now that is that is that that is that is
a concern yeah I don't know what else to
say oh I will remind you so the codes
are this is 2020 that's like a week
that's a childish code I have the real
codes are YouTube 50 if you're watching
on YouTube that saves you 50% and half
19 if you're watching on twitch that
they both save you 50% there's no you're
it's the same price no matter what but
very very exciting to have this battle
going on okay so that we've got we
talked about that let me do one more
Super chat and then we'll get to the
next story young dumb and baroque says I
love to hear the Republicans next
talking point that congressman Munez
couldn't have possibly predicted Biden's
candidacy during his December meeting
yeah listen they're gonna come up with
something they're gonna come up with
something no matter what okay next let's
go to this interview with Fox News and
let me see if I can I actually want to
put a tweet up let's see a real Donald
Trump no I think I actually tweeted it
let me see if I can find this tweet okay
here it is so Donald Trump we can get
away from this Donald Trump after a week
of impeachment hearings after two weeks
of impeachment hearings actually
promoted he's going on Fox & Friends and
he did and it went horribly wrong and
basically there were two main things
that I wanted to point out from this
interview number one Trump seemed very
much unwell Trump seed seemed he was
rambling he was incoherent
he was conjured
addicting himself and it was a complete
and total mess but he also seemed to
blurt out for the first time that indeed
the military aid to Ukraine was
connected to pushing Ukraine to quote
investigate corruption which means smear
Joe Biden so let's just start listening
to the beginning of this a little bit
and then I'll skip forward to the part
about the quid pro quo but he sounds
very much off
just listen good morning good to have
you on Fox and Friends today as you sent
in your tweet another slow news week
let's start with the fact that the story
that Griff just brought us that it
sounds like a former FBI lawyer
it sounds like was doing something with
the FISA application that person got
removed yeah
even Steve Doocy doesn't know what the
hell is going on he's just floating it
to Trump and this goes to your argument
that somebody at the FBI was out to get
you right well it certainly does and
they were spying on my campaign and it
went right up to the top that's untrue
and everybody knows it and now we're
gonna find out
you have Bull Durham who's supposed to
be the toughest I've never met him never
spoke to him but he's supposed to be the
smartest and the best and he works he
works for Bill Barr who's in a great
Attorney General we would maybe have
ended this thing a lot sooner had he
been there originally but you have some
people that are great people now and
patriotic people they love our country
and this was spying her in my campaign
something that has never been done in
the history of our country this was mine
so that's not true overthrow attempt at
the presidency they tried to overthrow
the presidency this is a disgrace but
well I'm not surprised to see it it's
just starting to come up I think this is
nothing compared to what you'll see over
the next couple of weeks these media
these media outlets are saying that the
FBI lawyer manipulated and altered key
documents related to that warrant
application so that they could get
permission to surveil Carter page he was
on with Maria warnings with Maria a few
minutes ago and he says it's a cover-up
listen they
have just been putting false information
out there to the meat and the media the
Democrats
oh I hung out with Carter page at
Politico last year and that is a whole I
mean I can't I don't want to get
derailed now but maybe if the stream
goes long enough I'll talk about Carter
pages and their allies in washing their
Washington in the media constantly
pushing lies after lies and then finally
this gets picked up by a court it gets
picked up by the Comey McCabe FBI and
they got a warrant a fraudulent warrant
I believe to spy on myself as a way of
getting into the Trump's yeah there has
been a continued cover-up to this very
day we still don't have the truth but
hopefully we'll get that soon how does
this compare with what happened with
that Ukraine conversation Democrats want
to impeach you because of that
conversation now you start slamming boy
this looks pretty bad so my conversation
was a perfect conversation and the
Ukrainian president said what are they
talking about they must think we're nuts
in this country by the way anybody else
you can hear a Sharpie in the background
you can hear there's there's a sharpie
noise that we can identify as a sharpie
no this conversation was flawless it was
appropriate it was perfect it was nice
it was everything and they even said
that they can't said it no compare that
as they try it impeach and by the way
they've looked like fools over the last
five days these interviews were and
these were their witnesses these were
this was the best they've got so that's
a lie in fact there were a number of
witnesses that could potentially be even
more damaging which Republicans and the
White House have been blocking so that's
another lie this is how so listen even
us right like you guys me on our first
watch of this if we're just sitting
there waiting for you know our car oil
change to be done or whatever and we
watch this we might have the general
sense that you know Trump is being
hyperbolic but it's lie after lie even
we would have trouble keeping up with
that do you think like your average Fox
News viewer is going to even critique
anything that's being say it's just lie
after lie after lie
not even get into this it's been
incredible now what you're going to see
I predict will be perhaps the biggest
scandal in the history of our country
political scandal but I guess that's the
biggest he may be right about that but
he's not talking about himself so and
that's the other funny thing the hosts
are visibly confused by what Trump is
talking about to see things that are
gonna be incredible if it's if it's done
right and I purposely stay out
I tell bill bar to handle everything I
wouldn't have to I could get very much
involved but I purposely don't and I
haven't and you know what it's better
that way I guess I am I don't have any
obligation legally to do that but I've
let them handle it so you have a Pfizer
report coming out which the word is its
historic that's what the word is that's
what I hear and if it's historic you're
gonna see something in it the hosts
don't the hosts want to help them they
don't know what on earth he's talking
about look at look at Steve Doocy face I
mean okay Ainsley Earhardt always has
this exact look so we can't glean much
from that he'll need it starts getting
visibly confused perhaps even more
importantly you have Durham coming out
shortly thereafter he's the US attorney
and he's already announced it's criminal
and we'll see what happens
mr. president you what you have you have
a lot of very very bad people and a lot
of people say deep state I don't like to
use the word deep said he doesn't like
to use it actually he's talked about the
deep state before and he's a total deep
state conspiracy really mr. president
you say it could be historic you have
suggested in the past that this might go
much higher than the Department of
Justice that's right it goes all the way
up to trump with the FBI during the
Obama administration are you suggesting
it could actually go up into the West
Wing of the Obama dealing at the highest
levels of government they were spying in
my campaign this is untrue pinyon I said
it a long time ago
they were spying on my campaign that's
my opinion
okay either they were spying on his
campaign or they weren't and that's a
conspiracy but what does it mean that
his opinion all right now let's get
forward to the key moment there are
basically two primary things that we're
gonna find here and the exact time code
I think it's at about 550 okay so here's
what you're gonna hear you are going to
hear Donald Trump bring up this crowd
strike server conspiracy theory for
which there is no evidence you're
actually you know good for him you're
actually going to see Steve do she say
are you sure about that because even
Steve Doocy and kilmeade will do his
confused face even they know that none
of this stuff is true and then Trump is
going to link he's publicly going to
blurt out he's going to link the money
to Ukraine and the investigations into
corruption which we now know to be code
for smearing Joe Biden okay that's what
we're gonna see here it's very
interesting they have the server right
from the DNC Democratic National
Committee who has the sir know the FBI
went in and they told him get out of
here you're not get it we're not giving
it to you once you see the server to
CrowdStrike or whatever it's called
which is a country which is a company
owned by a very wealthy ukrainian and i
still want to see that server you know
the FBI has never gotten that server
that's a big part of this whole thing
why did they give it to a Ukrainian
company where you even Steve Doocy says
I have to interject because you are you
sure and by the way Ainsley Earhardt
space still has not moved the entire
time and then this is where Trump now
actually links the aid and the
investigations blurting out what
everybody has been trying to deny from
seven if you know seven people or
however many have testified now are you
sure they gave it to Ukraine well that's
what the word is
that's what is actually in my phone call
of you know I mean I asked it very
point-blank because we're looking for
corruption this tremendous corruption
will so he just says in my phone call I
asked point-blank about Biden DNC
CrowdStrike ba-ba-ba-ba-ba okay and in
the same breath now he's
talk about age why should we be giving
hundreds of millions of dollars to
countries when there's this kind of
corruption the average FoxNews viewer is
not gonna pick up on this a lot of
people are not going to pick up on this
this is Donald Trump he was pushed this
is a friendly interviewer this is Steve
douchey right
he says are you sure about that
conspiracy theory that alone gets Trump
to blurt out I've been asking them to
look into this specific thing and of
course we know when there's a power
imbalance between the President of the
United States and the brand-new
president of Ukraine that's a that's
asking right it's you're gonna do this
and he says I asked them to do it I mean
listen why should we be giving them all
the money that we give him he's publicly
linking for the first time the aid to
the pushing them to do investigations
let's just go back III let's now just
listen to the entire thing I see people
saying we should listen to the entire
thing together let's just take one more
listen listen to the evolution of this
it's very interesting they have the
server right from the DNC Democratic
National Committee who has the sir know
the FBI went in and they told him get
out of here you're not kidding we're not
giving it to you
they gave the server to CrowdStrike or
whatever it's called which is a country
which is a company owned by a very
wealthy Ukrainian and I still want to
see that server you know the FBI has
never gotten that server that's a big
part of this whole thing why did they
give it to a Ukrainian company well you
sure they did that are you sure they do
Dave it to Ukraine well that's what the
word is and that's what I asked actually
in my phone call of you know I mean I
asked it very point-blank because we're
looking for corruption this tremendous
corruption we're looking for why should
we be giving hundreds of millions of
dollars to countries when there's this
kind of corruption so there it is that's
what Devon Nunez spent hour after hour
after hour denying this is what they've
all been denying all along and there is
Trump saying exactly what it is that is
supposedly being denied it's stunning
it's truly truly stunning okay so we did
that next I want to get to
this but well before I do that let me I
have so many people to thank and okay
let me do super chats first if you're
just joining we are live on twitch and
YouTube we've never done this before and
we have a contest going between YouTube
and twitch which right now YouTube is
winning five nothing but we'll update
that in a moment
qq- asks via super chat on youtube does
anybody remember Blagojevich I do a lot
of people have definitely forgotten John
our says Fox News cared more about facts
than Trump in that interview yeah in
some weird sense even these clowns had
to say you know what you're talking
about sir I don't know that what you're
saying makes any sense I believe that
there are still free super chats
available if you are a YouTube a Premium
Member I believe that through November
29th you have free super chats click the
dollar sign and I believe that you can
send those in over on Twitch let me say
thank you to bottig for subscribing with
twitch Prime and definitely remain for
subscribing with twitch Prime Nate Davis
174 GATS je Fiore no flip switch
voiceless V Tubby's clone 7 monkish
gamer & purtz e thank you so much
alright now let's update how the twitch
versus YouTube paddle is going it was
very very ugly it was 5 nothing when I
last checked Daniela Velez signed up
with the YouTube 50 code making it 6
nothing Jeremy Mullen has signed up with
the YouTube 50 code making it 7 nothing
and Kristian Garcia signed up with no
coupon code so it's 7 nothing youtube /
twitch this is it's getting bad but we
do have 8 of 15 web site members and if
we get to 7 we will open up the phone
lines and we actually might do that
quite soon it'll be great on a Sunday
evening just to hear what's on people's
minds see what we should be covering
during the week but yes it is the codes
are so the website is joined pakman.com
there's the code youtube' 50 for youtube
and then there's the code
half nineteen for twitch they both save
you forty percent so there's no
advantage everybody gets the same deal
but it's eight zero YouTube right now
which is surprising I must say okay next
thing I want to talk about we've been
talking about Donald Trump's health now
I want to make sure that I'm clear here
we've talked about Donald Trump's mental
health and we've talked about Donald
Trump's physical health the mental
health I'm not going to talk about today
that relates to cognitive decline
there's a I'm not going to talk about it
so the point is that's not what we're
talking about today Donald Trump's
physical health has been a question mark
for a long time back when he was running
he we now know forced his doctor former
dr. Harold Bornstein to write this
absolutely ludicrous letter saying that
Donald Trump would be the healthiest
president to ever be president which of
course is a crazy thing for a doctor to
say if the doctor hasn't examined any
other presidents how is that something
he could say about Trump
additionally Trump is clinically obese
doesn't exercise and eats a terrible
diet the idea that he's even healthier
than the previous president nevermind
every other president is laughable so
already very weird then we found out
that Donald Trump was claiming to be 6-3
he's pictured next to Barack Obama who I
believe is only supposed to be 6:1 and
Obama's taller
he's been pictured next to Tom Brady Tom
Brady towers over him and I think
Brady's supposed to be 6-2 or something
like that so Trump lies and the reason
he probably lied about his height is he
wanted to be I think he claimed to be
6-3 to 39 which would be like just shy
of clinically obese and of course if
he's only 6 feet or 511 then you know
he's obese so then we find out that last
weekend he gets taken to Walter Reed
Hospital the hospital didn't know he was
going we've now since learned that when
when they know Trump is going they block
off corridors certain things are done
they didn't do it cuz they didn't know
he was going he was there for two hours
the White House claimed that he was
getting a jump on his 20/20 physical
they said you know listen what the hell
we're just hanging around this weekend
let's go over
to the hospital and just do two hours of
tests to get ahead on the 20/20 physical
who would believe that doesn't make any
sense when Trump left it was noted that
and I think I actually have the picture
here just to be thorough yeah I believe
that this is Trump leaving with his
doctor Shawn Connelly who rode with
Trump on the way back from the hospital
now this is unusual because for security
reasons the the doctor travels with
Trump but doesn't typically ride with
Trump but okay he had just been at the
hospital if you believe that it was just
for some tests why would his doctor be
riding with him it doesn't really make
sense but fine Trump arrives a few days
ago in Austin Texas Donald Trump you'll
notice this doesn't look like the normal
stairs that Trump comes down Trump
coming down a lower exit from Air Force
One and you will notice that right
behind Trump is his doctor who gets
directly into Trump
that's life okay so Trump comes down he
waves very weirdly in a very strange way
but that's okay he can wave however he
wants comes down short steps which we
might guess you know maybe they want to
reduce the risk if he were to trip and
fall and you will see Secret Service
guys here and then is Melania
I'm sorry Ivanka is this some
avant-garde or Melania who who Fortran
ascendency which one is it okay it's
Ivanka and then Shawn Connelly comes off
as well and then rides with Trump this
is not normal right I mean this this is
not the way that the president normally
travels traveling with the doctor so am
I trying to make fun of Trump for being
obese of course not it's nothing to make
fun of but even when what the White
House says makes sense it's often a lie
when it doesn't make sense it's
definitely a lie and I don't believe
that at this point we have been told the
truth about this visit we don't know
what's going on Trump's doctor is now
riding around in the car with him I
don't know what's going on and you know
the White House is formally denied that
he has chest pain had chest pain or you
know there's the possibility of a panic
attack or whatever something's going on
and I believe that it is just something
that we should know that's it we should
we should just know what it was
okay let me answer a few more Super
chats here all alvaro coddled Vidal
Cardozo
says you're awesome thank you I
appreciate that
Ravenna Denver sends a super chat thank
you I appreciate that
Jonah and gocta says appreciate your
work and Robert clobber says don't you
think the DNC should chop down to the
debate stage it's ridiculous and seems
like the debates do nothing at this
point yeah so there's two things there
let's actually look at the polling since
you brought it up there's two things
going on one is that there are too many
people on the stage the other thing is
that the later in the game this gets the
less the debates do in the sense that
the longer we go the candidates are
known their positions widely speaking
are known
and unless there's a major gaffe or just
like an embarrassingly bad kill shot
that someone suffers the polling is not
going to move as much the further in
that we get especially as more and more
people are decided what could move it
would be if instead of having you know
ten people on the stage we had five or
something like that that would
definitely be better now let me also
pull up debate wiki I want to see how
things are going for qualification for
the next debate because that's another
thing let's see sixth debate
qualification so right now we have Biden
Sanders Warren Budaj edge Harris and
Klobuchar I mean listen Klobuchar is
polling what is she pulling Klobuchar is
polling 1.5 percent it's like it's time
to go you know Harrison Buddha judge
okay and we may see steyr yang or Booker
there Oh
so tell Tulsi Gabbard may finally be
gone which will be good that'll at least
clear the debates light the the stage
slightly but we may end up with nine
people still and it's just too many it's
just too many people
Michael Leyva says thanks for making
great content thank you very much I
appreciate that all right let me get
over to twitch and see what's going on
with what people are saying Kiko 73 says
I tried signing up with twitch is it
showing that I have or no I'm not seeing
your name as having signed up Kiko I
don't know what's going on let me say
thank you to fox mccloud for signing up
on twitch mysterious Wolverine bonjah SH
Jon Hamm a link slab hard cheese Nico
lavrin and gizmo girl 85 thank you
alright let's now see how things are
going with our YouTube vs twitch battle
right now it is 8 to 0 YouTube is
winning in terms of website memberships
this is this is not looking good Joel
Connell has signed up with the YouTube
50 coupon code that makes it it's
actually 7-0 YouTube that makes it 8-0
YouTube and Patti Conrad has signed up
making it 9-0 YouTube and we do have 10
of 15 website members geez this is I
mean listen
we there are nearly 4000 people watching
over on YouTube and only 700 on Twitch
so that that does make some sense but
twitch is getting crushed right now if
we do get 5 more members I will open the
phone lines oh it looks so oh I see yeah
I also was gonna do I was gonna check
out a couple of of the voicemails that
have been coming in sometimes people
like to listen to that we're just going
through a lot of stuff that I've got on
my computer it's Sunday night and it's a
short week so we're not going to get to
a lot of this stuff the phone lines are
not open if we get 5 more members then I
will open them up but let's see what's
happening on the voicemail line just
what we've been chatting here let's see
let's take a listen and see what's on
people's minds hey well that kind of
surprised me then I went to the
voicemail I'm just watching your life
show and I think at the moment bit right
like I said the phone lines are not yet
open I don't just you know hang out and
pick up the phones all day but we will
open them maybe but let's listen David
yeah interesting uh with bootleg I think
he might pull off a Obama like take over
I believe in the future but been fast
and I was away this week in Mexico
fascinated with catching up in the week
of testimony between hell and the other
side I can't remember his name at the
moment just all right well checking in
very good I don't see who else is
calling
I don't know veteran I think the
impeachment and all this has gone on
pretty far it's like a traitor
that's like tyranny that's like you've
got to be removed I think maybe public
impeachment I mean public execution for
being a traitor and I spent six years in
the Army during that Cold War I know
it's pretty serious right have a great
day thank you for your work all right
and thank you uh thank you as well for
calling in but
see and again the phone lines are not
yet open but we are considering opening
them and it looks like we're only Oh
Jelani Fraser has just signed up with
the twitch code okay that is new member
number eleven and it makes the advantage
for YouTube for twitch
nine to one but at least it's not going
to be a it's not going to be a shutout
which i think is good listen to a couple
more voicemail Wow actually that one
that is another one of these so
disconnected from reality trumpets that
I'm actually going to save that that I
may use that tomorrow we'll call that
disconnected trumpets that may be one
that makes the show because that is out
there let's take a listen to a couple
others yeah well you know you guys gonna
do once the truth comes out and all your
liberal lives and stuff or wow we're
hitting the jackpot tonight might know
what are you guys gonna do do you guys
gonna root for when all the bad guys are
locked up when Obama's and Clinton's and
bushes all the deep Staters are locked
up what are you guys gonna do then
Oh Bunga is gonna pay your bills it's
going well listen actually trumping in
power has been way better for my show
than any of these people so then getting
locked up I'll be fine but the country
is going to be screwed Wow okay I'm
gonna save that one as well because this
is it's so difficult to get good
voicemails and we actually have quite a
few so we'll call that guy who locked up
people okay all right let's see oh that
same person left a second voice or some
more voicemail for you what you
songul [ __ ] get on the train with
Trump and let's make this country a
better place
quit spreading lies and deception trying
to tear down a good man right yeah so
that he will never see reason that
that's not someone who is ever going to
you know say you know what it actually
does seem like maybe Trump has not been
has not been great for us let's do our
liking these let me know if you want to
hear a co these are real yeah this is
totally real you this people don't
understand we get a hundred of these a
day we got a hundred of these a day let
me say thank you to a couple of other
people thanks to repr seven one four for
subscribing with twitch prime hoagies
casey keiko 73 there you are subscribed
for two months with twitch primes john
squarest n' thank you as well over on
the YouTube side because we are
screaming on both thank you - oh I guess
that's it nobody else - think Robert
hopster has signed up but not using
either of the coupon codes Erin Lowe has
signed up not using either coupon code
very good alright so YouTube still
beating twitch nine to one but we have
13 of 15 website members if these
voicemails aren't firing people up to
get the phone lines open then I don't
know what will
let's listen to a couple others and yeah
I'll open the phone rights I'm guessing
two more people will sign up coming from
somewhere alright let's let's take a
listen to another hi David
why do you think there were Democrats
are just trying to hang the president on
one one impeachment charge wire and
they're like 30 or 40 this is actually a
good question let me hear the rest of my
throw up you thank you
yeah so arguably it's a mistake actually
not to bring impeachment hearings around
emoluments I think the Yemen Fiasco is
arguably impeachable but III do
understand that I mean listen we've had
35 hours of testimony already and it's
still muddled and I'm still getting
calls from people who don't have any
even the slightest idea what it is
that's
on so I think that it's I understand why
this is over one thing but the thing is
if they don't get anything out of this
you can't then say alright well now
we'll bring impeachment over emoluments
it's it's not gonna work and I do think
that in the end you you either have to
get the PR benefit that knocks Trump out
or Democrats are gonna get nothing from
this and it'll be one of the bigger
political failures let's listen to
another yes just like do you think that
it might cause racism if President Trump
don't win like he's come so many jobs
for like black people and its all-time
high and so many people's are food
stamps and so many of these guys are
working now do you think that they might
turn around and retaliate like the
Democrats have retaliated against him to
come then if listen one or one of them
got in they wouldn't have a job or
anybody so what do you think on me at
and to how do you stop him this guy is
building walls he's doing all this stuff
and I wonder how these guys down no
listen Trump Trump's presence is what
has coalesced and catalyzed racism it I
don't know that it's created it I think
it's always been there but it's made the
racism more comfortable being out in the
open but how do you stop them at this
but I think it's just you vote them out
I don't know of any other I don't know
of any other way yes all everybody who's
been calling in is allowed to vote by
the way Alex W sent a super chat you
skipped my last super chat I asked about
your live streaming live streaming
frequency yeah it's just random like
today I'm doing a Sunday night stream
because we've got a short week this week
and because of Thanksgiving and I'll be
out of town everybody's going to be out
of town out of town so I just there's no
set thing that we do it's just you know
whatever whatever sort of happens
happens and that's it it's an exciting
thing let's listen to one more how about
oh this might be a local to me call it
sir ah yes I uh I wouldn't like to
disclose my name but so you know but
anyways
Trump has more blood on his hands you
know between Ukraine Syria
the shootings in Texas and you know the
synagogue's the rabbi's and everything
which has certainly been fueled by hate
you know you know I just it's you know
at Jesus I feel I feel insulted yeah you
and me both my friend it's it's very
very bad okay let's say thank you to a
couple of other people and I think we
are going to open the phone lines amy
anderson signing up signing up with code
youtube' 50 that makes the youtube lead
ten to one
Wow Andrew Hollis signing up with no
coupon code but that is 15 members and
then Robert Nathan signing up with no
coupon code so we do have 16 we are
going to open up the phone lines let me
in fact do that right now and people can
call in the number is six one seven
eight three zero 47 50 let me get myself
connected and then I'm going to read
some super chats and do some twitch
thank-yous whoa sorry about that
whoa there we go everything getting a
little crazy here there we go all right
six one seven eight three zero 47 50 is
the number if folks want to call in
thanks to NPO AI for subscribing with
twitch Prime
thanks for Falconer Navy Spurs and
nikooei for subscribing with twitch
Prime I very much appreciate that over
on YouTube T Machine checking in with 50
Argentinian pesos Argentina of course my
birth country I think at the current
exchange rate that's about a penny no
it's like a dollar it's bad though not
radical enough but like the content I
live in Argentina do you still have any
connection I have cousins I have uncles
I have great aunts and uncles I have
friends yes I and I go I visit regularly
I have very much very much connection to
Argentina okay let's see here all right
I'm gonna get connected and then we will
hear from some folks thank you for
calling in to the David Pakman show
please do not use speakerphone have your
question ready and listen for David
to call out your area code sage advice
let's see who we've got a lot of a lot
of folks that we know and also a lot of
folks we don't know let's see who's
calling for the 941 area code 941 what's
going on today hello 941 hmm
9 401 are you there yep I'm oh hey yeah
now we can hear you what's going on yeah
one your opinion on what happens if it
looks like it is Trump does get
impeached by the house right and what I
mean by that is the Senate of course
mobile boom you know there's not going
to be you know there's I mean no
Republicans are going to cross over my
opinion basically agree OSI kind of
speaker delay that's weird
nope how does that play up until the
election and what if after the election
the Democrats take control the Senate
could it be that the president from
one's re-election and then immediately
gets removed so you're saying
Trump wins re-election but Democrats
take control of the Senate then there's
impeachment or the impede there's an
impeachment for something else or it's
delayed a vote is delayed until then and
then Democrats who then will control the
Senate actually remove them is that the
idea yeah I mean I imagine you can still
the house can vote right now I mean I
can imagine there's some expiration on
the articles of impeachment yes I think
that what you're bringing up is very
interesting the only thing is you know
I've pointed out it's an uphill battle
for Democrats in the Senate in 2020 it's
possible but it's an uphill battle
they've got to get five tough races to
go to their side and not really lose
anything and even then you still need
2/3 in the Senate as the very astute
twitch viewers are pointing out so just
taking control is not necessarily even
enough so it would be very very
difficult now it is
true that if Democrats take control
Republicans may be also ones not running
for re-election might be more willing to
just do the right thing but I I mean
listen it's what you're bringing it's
good that you're thinking about these
scenarios but it's still a pretty big
uphill battle yeah no matter what I
think it's gonna be funny when they do
and I think the house is gonna beat and
it will be funny when the election does
come and we're voting for what is an
officially impeached president that's
except that would be very interesting
and I think you're right I do think that
the house III have a couple articles
highlighted for tomorrow let me see if I
don't have it in front of me but it
looks like they want to at least
continue with more hearings and I think
there's a good chance the house votes to
impeach and of course the Senate doesn't
convict and then honestly maybe even
Trump than wins re-election all right
thanks for the call I appreciate it
great to hear from you let me say thanks
to Morgan who sent a $50 super chat
saying no need to read this just saying
thanks also people asking are there
still free super chats there are if
you're a YouTube premium subscriber I
think this is YouTube's challenge to
twitch prime with Amazon Prime if you're
a YouTube premium subscriber until
November 29th you have free super chats
you can send click the dollar sign I
believe is what you have to do also let
me say thanks to Michael Leyva
Michael Leyva has signed up with the
coupon code youtube for a crushing you'd
the youtube code crushing the twitch
code and I think we have to chalk it up
and take the loss this evening for
twitch let's go next to our caller from
the 401 area code our friendly neighbors
to the South and Rhode Island
potentially hello 401 401 oo my question
oh yeah hello yes good good so I wanted
to touch upon the recent reports
surrounding Devon Nunez and how he was
Chokin in Vienna so there have also been
a recent reports that Devon Nunez has
claimed that he is going to file a
lawsuit against
CNN and I believe the daily beast for
breaking out these reports right now
considering that these sued a fake cow
yeah what do you think do you think he's
just bluffing or do you think he's
actually serious with it with I mean
listen I think I think he may well filed
a lawsuit in the same way that you know
tulsi gabbard sued YouTube or something
or Google I guess it was or something
like that but you know I don't think
it's gonna go anywhere and you know
unfortunately so the you're right that
the reports first came out about new
neces involvement which we talked about
earlier in the stream and then of course
a bunch of people denied it and then it
turns out that he filed all sorts of
taxpayer paid expenses fifty-seven
thousand dollars worth of flights and I
think accommodations at the exact time
that it's being alleged he was having
these meetings so the narrative that
it's a lie is already falling apart and
I don't even know that it's gonna make
any sense for him to file any kind of
lawsuit sure I mean especially with a
discovery process and considering that
the source is from less harnesses lawyer
there's a really a lot of credibility so
a discovery process would be damaging
not only but yeah I I don't I said this
earlier I don't think that Lev Parnas
through his so left Parnas for people
who don't know or you missed the
beginning of the stream is the indicted
Giuliani associate who now is claiming
he can put Devon newness in Vienna
meeting with Victor shokhin
participating in the smear attempts of
Biden I don't think he would allege that
through unless he could prove that that
took place so I would be shocked if he's
making that up quite frankly sure all
right all right thank you I hope you let
your brain won't be in recovery mode for
too long because we do have to get back
to work tomorrow yeah go on
take care yep let's see let's go next to
a lot of interesting and a lot of
interesting area codes that let's go to
- one - I've always good to hear from
someone who I guess at some point had a
New York City connection - one - what's
going on yes that's you your connection
is important though that's the only
thing is there anything we can do about
the connection
oh yeah that better you know it is I'm
curious what did you do I can imagine
oh yes you with the phone anyway so my
question is it seems like California and
New York are pretty much full sale
funding the fight against homelessness
and the government isn't really stepping
up to do anything against the fight for
homelessness I mean what do you think
they can do more in the realm of
tackling the issue of homelessness we
actually talked about this on our
members-only bonus show last week as
California is taking some serious steps
to try to fight homelessness yeah I have
been talking for a while that many of
the homelessness related problems are a
matter of just political will and
distribution of resources and we've seen
really interesting tests like for
example it was in a town in either Utah
or Colorado I don't remember exactly now
where they said let's just give let
let's give the homeless population
houses there might have been the the
homeless veteran population some
subsection houses in health care and the
cost of that was less than the total
societal costs of the homelessness and
lack of medical care so you know if you
had a federal government by that I mean
a president that actually cared about
this stuff a lot of these issues could
be solved very quickly with federal
funds going to States in proportion to
the degree to which they have a homeless
problem and I mean there it's it's a
relatively simple problem to solve it is
more complicated than for example like
hunger hunger we could solve overnight
if we decided we were going to do it but
the federal government essentially
subsidy for farmers and the middlemen in
the distribution chain food extremely
stimulative to the economy as well yeah
so I mean listen weed there's a lot the
federal government can do but we've got
to get a federal government run by
someone who cares about that right and
one more point I noticed because I was
living in Ohio not too long ago that no
new housing projects were going up
anywhere that I could see
and it is a conservative state swing
state they say but it's very
conservative he's recently moved to New
York and there's housing projects going
up everywhere if you look at New York's
plan to fight almost miss they're
essentially funding the fight against
homelessness by themselves there's
really no effort from federal government
or the White House to try fish yeah it's
disgusting and you know it's same
similar things going on with climate
similar things going on with you know in
so many different areas thanks for the
call
appreciate it sounds like you're you
know maybe at a hockey game or something
so I'm gonna let you go go let me say
thanks to a few other people I want to
say thank you to see this is where
twitch is very different than YouTube on
YouTube it's like I'm getting super
chats from Kevin I'm getting one from
Nolan I'm getting one from you know who
else here
okay those are a few examples on Twitch
I just had someone called I spank my
monkey every night subscribe with twitch
prime so it's a very very different
scene over on Twitch also thanks to
bridges for subscribing with twitch
prime over on YouTube
Steven Andrew says with the holidays
coming how do we convince our Fox News
loving family that were not socialists
and want free things because we want to
vote Bernie you know that that's tough
I actually I have a couple videos about
how to have conversations that won't
ruin relationships at Thanksgiving so I
won't do it here but check out my videos
on that let's see let me go to our
caller from the three one five area code
who's calling today from three one five
hey David it's Nick from Syracuse hey
Nick hi I'm just curious to get your
thoughts on Giuliani threatening Trump
with quote-unquote insurance comfort oh
I didn't see that what does that even
mean I don't even you yeah so he was on
I'm not sure what show was recently but
nobody asked him you know have you seen
the report that Trump may or may not
throw you under the bus I have so let me
see I found an article three to seven
hours ago
let's see Rudy Giuliani
detailed his insurance policy that he
has repeatedly mentioned when asked
about Trump throwing him under the bus
essentially Giuliani wrote on Twitter
that it was a sarcastic term but that he
does have potentially compromising files
he had in a safe concerning former Vice
President Joe Biden and his son hunter
what I don't understand is if the
documents are about Biden and hunter how
is that anything that would prevent
Trump from turning on him yeah I mean
that just brings me delight to see a
wedge being driven between them yeah
that is interesting I'm gonna look into
that more and maybe talk about it on on
tomorrow's show but thanks for pointing
that out I hadn't seen that you know
here's the thing Trump will turn all
these people basically will turn on
whoever when it's the when it's their
ass on the line essentially and it
wouldn't be surprising to see Trump turn
on Giuliani it wouldn't be surprising to
see Giuliani turn on Trump I mean I just
I just wouldn't be surprised by any of
it yep it's just rap jumping off a
sinking ship
absolutely absolutely all right all
right thanks for the call appreciate it
yep thank you
we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
people wondering how long the queue is
it's about 25 people right now I'm sort
of skipping around a little bit using a
very sophisticated algorithm let's go
next to our caller from the to10 area
code two-one-zero as people know we have
a number of trolls in the San Antonio
area and a lot of good callers as well
so we'll go to 2 1 0 next 2 1 0 are you
there yep hey Chris they made a great
sake about watch like countless hours of
your show and a lot of other progressive
style shows and thank you so appreciate
that yes I wanted to throw out a
question you know and all the hours I've
watched I haven't really seen anyone
talking much about like the meat dairy
or egg industry and I feel like that's
kind of like a pretty big thing that you
know progressives could really care
about it's good it affects the
environment and people's health and you
know they
like the biggest a big business though
wasn't sure what your thoughts were
about that well I think it's important
to talk about in proportion I believe
that in terms of all emissions animal
agriculture is 11% so it's not you know
it's mostly other stuff I think it's
about 11 percent so I've said I think it
does make sense to you know it seems
that what's better for the environment
is also what's better health-wise which
is you know the Mediterranean diet is
one that seems to be widely at least
correlated with if not causing a healthy
you know longevity and outcomes so you
reduce red meat certainly which I do I
only read red meat probably you know
five times a year you reduce poultry as
well but not as much as red meat and you
focus on you know healthy fats things
from nuts fish etc I think it's
important you know we want we want to be
adjusted to the reality which last I
looked I believe again animal
agriculture is 11 percent of emissions
so you know 80 89 percent is from other
stuff and it's a you know industrial
companies transportation etc etc so yeah
I think it's something good to talk
about and we want to talk about it
basically in proportion to the degree
that it's it's responsible right and
also you know relate to like the
disruption of and the Amazon at land
usage and just in general the the
trajectory that America is on and the
whole planet in terms of eating more and
more meat it's pretty like unsustainable
so I just think it'd be good if you know
more people talked about it especially
like at school you know when I was in I
remember like I'm 36 now and when I was
in eighth grade our health teacher said
oh you know milk is unhealthy and
everyone's like oh she's crazy she
actually got fired because she told
people that and now looking back like
that was completely true and it just
matters so much you know what people
learn growing up things like that yeah
so I think that you know that they've
got the government kind of has their
hands in that too in terms of what gets
taught at public schools so you know
it's really no question about that and
we've been talking about the the school
board issue is a big
in terms of what is and is not
importantly taught in school yeah yeah
well I just wanted to throw that out
there and and I kind of gone to kind of
on a journey myself the last couple
years where I've gotten into politics
also got into eating and eating
healthier and kind of relearning what
nutrition is and you know have what what
you know what I don't know you know with
what people eat and absolutely I think
that that's great and it's good for
everybody to take control of you know
their diets and all of that and I really
appreciate the call I hope to hear from
you again let me say thank you to night
owl 102 for subscribing with twitch
prime why bother
for subscribing with twitch prime is
well we are live on twitch and YouTube
right now really appreciate everybody
who's just checking in for a random
Sunday night stream
Terry James sent a super chat over on
YouTube if Trump was impeached in the
house not convicted in the Senate would
it still be an albatross on him for 2020
I really have no idea I really don't
know you could see it two ways you could
see it as he is impeached in the house
not convicted in the Senate and his
followers are completely reinvigorated
and he crushes re-election you could see
it as people become furious that
Republicans won't see reason and won't
do the right thing and Trump gets
removed I really don't know and it you
could make an argument either way I will
keep taking more super chat questions Oh
Jake Luna says do you think the large
debate fields might be on purpose to
obfuscate the opinions of less
establishment candidates since they
already have notability I don't think
it's that calculated actually I think
it's much more complex and and this
graphic that's on screen now we
discussed earlier and this will be
talking about this on tomorrow's program
as well but I think there's there's
quite a bit quite a bit to it okay let's
go to our next caller from the let's try
3 1 2 where is 3 1 2 Chicago area do I
remember that correctly
yeah that's ikkaku area hey how are you
I had a question about what do you think
about Bloomberg running I think that's
help Bernie how so I thinking support
from Biden and maybe Warren hmm that's
interesting yeah I mean I didn't I
didn't consider that the question is
going to be let's see if we can pull it
up you know can Bloomberg even get
himself into debates number one
Bloomberg yeah I mean so far we have we
just have nothing he just announced they
keep spending like thirty million
dollars yeah if he can get himself into
debates then maybe he will start to have
an impact I just don't see how he has
any impact if he doesn't get into the
debates so I'm gonna reserve judgment
about that you know I think that though
it may help Bernie in that Bernie's kind
of anti billionaires running the country
narrative maybe come front and center
with Bloomberg running and you can say
is this really is this country really
about a billionaire Republican and a
billionaire Democrat running against
each other these are the two people that
were choosing between so I think that
that that could be an interesting thing
for Bernie but I have to think about it
a little more that you know a lot of
people in the twitchchat are saying
there is no chance Bloomberg gets into
the debates over on the YouTube chat a
lot of people are saying does the exact
same thing so yeah I mean he it just may
be a non-factor in the end well I just
really think it would help with the
polling numbers but by lowering Biden's
points by at least three or four percent
I think that would yeah that could make
a difference that could be the
difference I mean right now that would
help Warren more than Bernie as long as
it doesn't hurt her but we'll follow it
and we'll see you know I'll tell you
what the how the polls move for sure all
right thank you okay great thank you let
me say thanks to a new website member
Darlene Johnson that is new member
number 18 of the evening thanks Darlene
I really appreciate that thank you - oh
I've got a couple other super chats to
read shannon Bennis wants to know what's
my personal opinion of buddha judge I'm
sure he's a very nice guy personally I
have no problem with him personally
I eat inshaa says nine percent is the
total aglet agricultural emissions in
the US okay yeah so my 11 percent number
maybe was worldwide or maybe I was just
wrong
thank you to totaram for the third month
in a row subscription with twitch prime
totaram asks what did Trump admit Trump
admitted let's just play it again just
because it's been a while and we talked
about this before I will play for you
just 45 seconds of video here during
which Trump admits he talked to Ukraine
about this CrowdStrike server DNC Dems
Biden thing and then he says and why
wouldn't we hold money back from them
basically linking the investigation into
quote corruption and the money for the
first time he doesn't even realize he
does it take a look they say with
Ukraine interesting it's very
interesting they have the server right
from the DNC Democratic National
Committee who has the sir know the FBI
wanted and they told him get out of here
you're not kidding we're not giving it
to you
they gave the server to CrowdStrike or
whatever it's called which is a country
which is a company owned by a very
wealthy ukrainian and i still want to
see that server you know the FBI has
never gotten that server that's a big
part of this whole thing why did they
give it to a Ukrainian company where are
you son are you sure they do Dave it to
Ukraine well that's what the word is yes
actually in my phone call of you know I
mean I asked it very point-blank because
we're looking for corruption this
tremendous corruption we're looking for
why should we be giving hundreds of
millions of dollars to countries when
there's this kind of corruption there is
so so he's doing it once again yeah or
he's doing it he says yes I was very
clear I asked them to do this and why
would we give them money if they're not
looking into the corruption as he sees
it it's there it is right there there it
is
Stephanie Coulter is asking me over on a
youtube super chat what do I think about
Deval Patrick entering the race is he oh
he's listed here listen I personally
like Deval Patrick and he is of the
presidential candidates he's the one I
know the best I mean I I interviewed him
a couple times when he was governor here
in Massachusetts and spent a little time
with him behind the scenes I've
interviewed Andrew yang a few three
times but I don't really know him
a personal level I really like Deval
Patrick personally but you know he works
at Bain Capital he was a lawyer for
coca-cola he's not you know he presided
over some pretty good progressive
changes here in Massachusetts but he's
not a progressive in the in the way that
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren is
and I don't think he has any chance
whatsoever so I think it'll be very very
it'll be moot in the end thanks to a swg
29 for the twitch Prime subscription and
also thanks to Nick field for signing up
at join pakman.com new member number 19
of the evening let's take a few more
phone calls let's go - oh I sit let's go
- 603 603 is New Hampshire which is an
interesting state you know live free or
die and all that stuff you have a lot of
conservatives you have a lot of liberals
in New Hampshire what's going on New
Hampshire
oh my max I don't actually live in New
Hampshire but oh dear I yeah I just
gives you the phone number
good I don't know but I've lived there
for four five years and it's a great
place well it took some tightness more
my my own question is about sort about
the climate change conversation and I
just the the aspects of how the world
has borders and where that like so many
people are gonna have to move away from
places that they live for years yes and
they're gonna be refugees and I'm not
sure our whole reasoning behind Borders
will help us a long term well I've said
before that you know there's all these
conversations about nationalism and who
cares what other countries say think do
we're doing it all for ourselves and
whatever climate change does not respect
country borders which of course are just
imaginary lines on a map sometimes there
are real fences sure but they're
essentially imaginary lines and so
whatever you think about you know
there's people with the one-world
government conspiracy theories and all
of this nonsense climate change has to
be dealt with globally it has to be a
global solution does that
I mean it is globalist or global ished
in the way Alex Jones says or whatever
no it's just like it as you're pointing
out this is an issue that can't be dealt
with by an individual country and that's
what makes it's so depressing that
Donald Trump has essentially done
nothing and actually made the issue even
worse yeah oh and then funny New
Hampshire story so over the past years
we've been going up to New Hampshire
there's always been this Confederate
flag just hanging out and I've always
been like there's a Confederate flag
there and no one has seen it every time
we go past I see it and just in the past
year went down and now it's an American
flag find that fascinate
okay that is interesting yeah that is uh
that that is something but all right
we'll keep up the good work thank you
very much good to hear from you yeah
thank you I do have a question here that
I want to address over on Twitch from a
gentleman named turkey bacon and cheese
and for people on the YouTube side this
is the top contributor ever on my twitch
channel of what are called bits which is
a whole other world that's going on over
there
turkey bacon and cheese has contributed
twenty eight thousand bits and has a
question what do you think it is about
your community that seems to attract
such a constant stream of militant
radical brigades whether regarding
Bolivia and tiny ilysm anti capitalism
Bernie or bust I don't think I don't
know that listen okay a fair question I
don't know that it's unique to my
community
but there is no question that when a
sliver of the left we have like a steady
flow of right-wingers that show up and
troll and do stuff when when someone
from the left disagrees with me and it
actually is like a slight of specific
particular movement on the left we do
get an influx of people that are not are
good they're not like our existing
audience it's it news starts to spread
that I'm off message and then people
come in and they try to take over you
know like the YouTube comments or the
subreddit or whatever I don't know what
it is but what I can tell you is I know
it's not my core audience for two
reasons one
if it were my core audience people would
be canceling memberships whenever we've
had these things where we get brigaded
no one cancels memberships because no
one who's angry is part of my existing
audience that supports me already and so
we just kind of like let it happen I
mean usually here's another interesting
thing turkey by the time it's happening
I've usually done like 30 more stories
and I'm onto something else
so I actually end up not even noticing
it that much which which is an
interesting thing but in any case it is
what it is let me say thanks to William
Lowry William Lowry is sending a super
chat on YouTube to say I'm actually from
twitch twitch gang rise up war on the
YouTube boomers so very very aggressive
messaging their primal says I just saw
Matt gates on CNN advocating for the
removal of cannabis from the federal
prohibited substance list and
expungement of prior convictions he said
if Kellyanne Conway okay boomer I don't
know if that's true but it sounds very
very funny and I also want to thank Troy
Baker for signing up at join pakman.com
let's see we'll take a couple more I do
have to go to bed it's I go to bed
pretty early on Sundays because it's
Mondays like a crazy crazy day let's go
to Sam from the 202 area code it's been
a few months since we heard from
actually it's been two months to the day
Sam how are you hey David I'm doing good
thank you
I just have an economic idea that I'd
kind of put together myself that I've
constructed a set of statistics around
it's kind of a live what I guess you
would call like a liberal Republican yes
that used to be a thing idea and it's
kind of an extrapolation of what Angie
yang does basically a universal basic
income where everyone gets a thousand
dollars but if you go over 25 under
$25,000 or if you're older than 60 the
number of month free money you get from
the government goes up exponentially and
this would replace welfare and food
stamps hold on a sec hello hello it goes
up exponentially like - how high yeah
like like if you're poor like basically
if you're really really poor you get you
get enough - you get a lot they
homeless basically I have to you
probably get the equivalent of a house
like you get the enough to buy a house
and all the things you would need to
live but the idea here hold on it's a
but let's go through it let's go to I
want it I want to make sure we're
thinking through so if you're in most
people get the thousand dollars a month
but if you if you live in New York so
over there everyone gets at least a
thousand dollars if you live in New York
City and you make under twenty five
thousand you get five hundred grand to
buy a house if that number goes up
higher and higher like if you're at
nineteen thousand dollars you get enough
to buy like basic utensils but the idea
you're behind free money instead of
instead of substances is because a lot
of people are poor for different reasons
often that have nothing that food stamps
can't fix like what if you're in debt to
a landlord or what if you have two
children a disabled child to take care
of and you're a single mom or what if
you have student debt there are a lot of
reasons why people could be poor and if
you get people money then they'll have
money to fix those problems that person
yes yes no money you can use to pay for
things and solve things but hold on so
if you make 25 grand a year you get a
thousand bucks a month if you make 19
and a year how much money do you get
just exponet
just put that exponentially like keep
going like nighttime twenty thousand
dollars ninety thousand dollars eighteen
etc it just goes up and up and up do you
know what exponential means yeah I do
it's when you multiply something and
then you multiply something again you
multiply the same thing by itself
repeatedly like three squared is nine
ten squares 100 I can go on all right
I'm not gonna ask you to go on because I
think we may have a slightly different
opinion let me call it an opinion as to
what exponential means but listen Sam
it's always so good to hear from you and
I'm glad to hear you're doing well oh by
the way yeah I'm just tired too if you
um will have to catch cast a movie for
for Trump beyond Bolton should be Peter
Dinklage I like that I like that and
people have asked me who would play me
in the movie and I've
said it should probably be Joseph
gordon-levitt or the guy who plays mr.
Schue on Glee would be fine and then
Kirk Cameron maybe looks wise would work
other than you know he's a complete
lunatic religious nut so that's a pro oh
and Jake Gyllenhaal yeah that's that's
the one Jake Gyllenhaal is the one that
actually might be the best oh and here's
an idea if it's yes
the younger Ronald Reagan that would be
cool okay Sam very good well we're gonna
hear from you again soon I I'm I trust
let me say thank you to Stephen Leonard
Stephen Leonard has signed up at join
pakman.com and his new member 21 of the
evening I will on twitch say thank you
to Bobby Ivan for subscribing with
twitch Prime young ghoul for subscribing
with twitch prime eared owl that sounds
painful for subscribing with twitch
prime Robert 51 as well over on YouTube
adhi asks me do I share most politics
with Richard Wolffe well he's a
socialist and I'm not so that that's a
pretty big that's a it's a pretty big
matzo ball hanging out there right
between the two of us name withheld says
David I have a question on immigration
why do we even need a wall couldn't we
just find come but fine companies for
hiring immigrants illegally or fine
landlords for not declaring income from
illegal immigrants is it an ethics thing
I Ellis I have said many times these are
two separate issues but I've said many
times if you really want to take the
issue seriously go after those who are
most benefiting from the status quo of
undocumented immigrants that we have and
that is companies who are almost never
held accountable
Stephanie Coulter asks what do you think
about the Bernie blackout I have
addressed that Stephanie so I don't want
to go into it again now but I am gonna
continue covering that on the broadcast
show let's pick up on our caller from C
why don't we go to the three three six
area code who's been holding on for
nearly forty minutes three three six
what's on your mind today hi David yes
that is
okay so I'm Joel from Washington and I
understand there's a two-party system
the United States was pretty ingrained
in our history yes I can't help but feel
a lot of the Americans specifically the
moderates will reluctantly vote for one
side easily citing the lesser of the two
evils argument and I feel like it's a
problem that I'm just not satisfied for
when I'm voting and you know I just have
one side that I don't really appreciate
like certain things they have but I
think certain things might be a good
idea and I just don't feel like the tea
party system encapsulate everything well
let's take it there's a lot there so
let's just deal with that a little bit
so it's there's the lesser of two evils
but it's also often by voting third
party you're actually helping the
candidate who is most different from
your views to win so what we would want
to look at there is something like
single transferable vote for example or
a variety of different systems that
that's number one number two are you are
you thinking that like are you saying
you're sort of neutral between left and
right like there's some things you like
about the left and some things you like
about the right I would say I've lean
more left on my politics generally but
there's not every single thing I would
agree on and I feel like a two-party
system doesn't really do that for me no
I totally agree with you but it's not
like you're sort of in the middle where
you you agree with enough of each side
where it's a tough thing for you to
decide who to vote for right it sounds
like you still no vote for yeah yeah
well listen I mean I agree with you with
the problem of the two-party system for
sure but I I sometimes I'm concerned
when people say you know the left and
right they both have some ideas I like
and some I dislike and it's hard for me
to know who to vote for because for most
people the things you would like about
one side are often much outweighed by
the things that disgust you about that
side I wouldn't even say it like a lot
of things on the right I just there's
some things I'm not too fond of on the
left either right alright that's what
it's not like the right has a better
what don't you like on the left what
don't you like on the left well I don't
exactly agree with everything to do with
abortion I think it should be like only
a first trimester thing okay well that's
just my opinion I and I know people will
disagree and that's fine
and what about cases of
like where the life of the mother is at
risk yeah I would say that's fine them
do you think I would I'm pretty open to
evolving on different issues I just you
know there's not I I agree with
flexibility on right do you think you
might feel differently about the
abortion issue if you were the type of
person by that I mean a woman that might
ever need an abortion probably you would
okay interesting interesting well that
might make me reckon reconsider my
opinion if I if I had that that sort of
awareness okay thank you so much I
really appreciate the call all right
thank all right very good let me say
thank you to okay let me address
something there are people over on
twitch saying that it's unfair that the
YouTube code says YouTube in it and the
twitch code doesn't that's fair that's
fair I didn't know we were gonna do this
YouTube versus twitch thing so if we
ever do this again I will have a code
that is a twitch code there are people
on twitch saying that they are furious
because the code doesn't say twitch in
it and therefore it is in some way
pejorative and rigged and fake so I'll
deal with that let's see here let's go
to the three zero one area code who's
calling from three zero one can you hear
me yes I can hey David this is derek
from the great state of maryland how are
you good thank you
quite an a predicament
and i would like to get your opinion
about something okay
okay so a little bit about me i am 24
years old and i am in a relationship and
i recently found out that my girlfriend
is a part of a facebook group and i'm
not really sure what to do and she's
been really bugging me out so I'm just
wondering like if you were in that
position what would you do if I was in
your position now let me ask you this is
this the first time you became aware
that she's Pro Trump became aware of it
and before when whenever I began
politics with her she would just sort of
brush-off so I had no idea what a
politics were how long have you been
dating here hold on you've been dating
someone for a year and you and you the
topic of what her politics are have
never been broached try to bring it out
then she would just ignore it or brush
it off so I never really knew who I was
she thought of issues didn't that strike
you as people didn't that's oh okay so
hold on she said she was a political or
she wouldn't answer the combination of
both concern instances she would just
sort of just not answer at all she would
be brushed off but other times I thought
asking her about her she would just say
she's not really sure in how old is she
she is 23 mm and how did you mean online
dating okay and are you're not a trump
supporter I take it well you know you
know I'm struggling with how could you
date someone for a year and not know
their politics because very often it
comes out in other ways even if she's
not answering overtly political
questions you know if you walk by a
homeless person for example oftentimes
particularly in a relationship that's
been going on for a year there would be
some comment made that would either be
an empathetic comment which would imply
someone on the left or it would be like
a why can't these people just get a job
which would suggest that they're on the
right I'm having a little bit of a hard
time wondering what you've been doing
for the year that you didn't figure out
what her politics are and then how did
you find out she's in a pro Trump group
on Facebook he left her phone and I just
got curious and I decided to scroll
through and I discovered the group and
she was part of it mm-hmm and are you
have you met her family her family she
has actually been trying to avoid that
from happening so now that I'm looking
back at it I think I should have noticed
all those red flags that I think you're
right you are she did not want me to
meet them I think that my simple probing
questions have had the effect of getting
you to the answers that you're looking
for I'm pretty dirty crazy man yeah
I need anything else today all right
very good okay thank you for the call
all right listen please someone someone
on twitch please clip that and please
clip the abortion phone call with the
previous person okay I want to upload
those separately
please clip it and somehow if someone
can get it to me or whatever all right I
got to go to bed I'm not kidding about
that we've got a huge a huge day this
week a huge week this day something like
that appreciate everybody who called in
signed up all of that very cool stuff I
think that the first twitch YouTube
Simas stream was very very successful I
will have a twitch coupon code ready for
next time and thank you to all new show
tomorrow all of that stuff but somebody
please clip those last two calls and I
look forward to uploading them direct